nick pavetta he's five and over the 319
era david fletcher leads it off
and his play line drive caught by xander
bogarts for a quick out two strikes to
count to shoghe otani
there's a breaking ball that's hit
toward the monster
and it's off the corner of the wall jd
martinez getting a rare spot start
defensively and shohei wheels into
second with a one-out double so there's
his 22nd extra base hit the most in the
majors
well here is mr trout
barry bonds i would say he's going to
take a seat though pavetta will strike
him out take that and that is out number
two it is griffin canning on the mound
for the angels tonight last turn around
friday against the dodgers he was very
very good earning a 9-2 win
and a swing and a miss by chavis
and it'll bring up jd martinez 3 40 with
10 home runs 33 runs batted in
iglesias no way he was going to get to
that one and jd
is now even with his teammate in hits
xander bogart's the batter
on the ground for rendon to get canning
out of the inning unscathed jared walsh
will lead things off here
a little flare martinez approaching and
makes the point
he hangs on for the out on man gone
didn't slow down
charged all the way slide that perfect
nice catch j.d
there's justin upton now
got him on a fastball two out single
here in the second and taylor ward will
be the next batter
ward sends a high fly ball into center
and verdugo collects it
to retire the side two down for hunter
red throw
tag to center trout back turning watch
this one go gone
just as we speak hunter renfro strikes
again and the red sox take a two nothing
lead dead center field at fenway to make
it two-zip takes this fastball middle
part of the plate head right on it full
extension oh he knew it was gone as soon
as he hit it too chavis struck out to
open the home half of the first
chavis chases the fastball to strike out
utero will lead things off and throwing
a lot of strikes tonight and another one
here to sit down butera one man gone
with a nice fluid release
effortless
three infielders on the right side for
one of the marvels in all of baseball
waved and missed he struck him out
another good inning here canning is
ready he's in front of one and two
bogarts awaits the pitch it's on its way
and he swings and misses that one struck
him out got him to chase a slider
so canning has picked up a few
strikeouts he's had four
so far in this spa game against the
first
13 batters that have
been sent up against him there's rafael
devers he's single to the opposite field
in his first try tonight
and a swing and a miss that was a good
looking slider struck him out and that's
how the inning will end
so here is anthony rendon
swaying adamus and another one for
pavetta as he sets down a real good
hitter out of the zone and chased by
rendon
two strikes here on walsh and pavetta
fires
and it's in there for strike three
and the inning is over pavetta has now
retired seven in a row and four of those
have been on strikeouts he's got six
runner at third two down
for bobby dolbeck
out of trouble in the fourth canning has
another strikeout and he's uh picked up
six of them so far tonight michael
chavis leading things off
a called strike three taken by chavis
that's a third time he struck out twice
swinging one looking
seven for canning tonight
so jd martinez who counting hasn't
gotten out so far tonight will be the
battery as a single and a walk oh and
one
and martinez sends the ball well head
out to right center field ward is there
just shy of the bullpen to make for a
one two three bottom of the fifth put up
some good swings here but you got to get
going soon
tried to go out there again with the
breaking ball show he hits it toward the
monster and gone
number 11 for ohtani wow double home run
tonight for shohei ohtani
now that's both times he's hit the ball
that way on breaking balls look how
strong he is a backdoor curveball and he
flicks it out two out base runner now
for marwyn gonzalez who had a first
pitch single back in the fourth
runner goes throw down by butera is in
plenty of time to get him and it'll be
andrews who took the loss on monday
night
against baltimore allowing a season high
three earned run and there's one away
with runners in scoring position and
that'll bring up jose iglesias second
and third with one gone and iglesias
shoots that into the right field corner
that's going to score him both
brendon can walk home
walsh scores and the angels have their
first lead of the night
what a swing that was for glaciers two
hits in the game
back in the lineup and producing 10 rbis
now on the season for iglesias
left-hander tony watson who has been
really really good all year brings up
bobby dalbeck who has walked two times
swaying a high fly ball twisting deep to
left center way back there and gone
bobby dalbeck crushes one
there it is a two-run homer to put the
red sox in front
he is homered in consecutive ball games
this one off the sign
and he has the sox back in the lead
bobby with a little curtain call and
adavino out of the bullpen he gets the
top of the order and run away into 2-2
swing and a miss down he goes he struck
out ohtani
two gone here's mike trout 3-2 again
and struck him out
95
he got the corner
trout took a step to first base he
doesn't argue i don't know if we've ever
seen him argue but he took it a fast
ball to end the top of the eighth so two
gone with the runner aboard now for
christian vasquez
a bouncer
a backhand throw and they get vasquez by
a step nice job by david fletcher
ranging to his right to stop that one
and here's matt
has 11 perfect appearances of at least
an inning that's the most of any major
league reliever two up two down justin
upton
swing in a miss he struck him out he
strikes out the side
who is pitching better than matt barnes
right now
nobody no one
he locks it up he picks up the save
number nine and the red sox grab game
one
4-3 the final score